I could picture myself cheating yeah and
I never did it but it's like I had those
thoughts so I can like see where you how
you can get there so tell me how you
deal with the conflict in a relationship
I used to be like baby and now I'm more
like I have words for this what do you
feel about monogamy I feel like I have
it in me to not be monogamous when it
comes down to it I'm also like too
jealous but like I'd kind of like want
the option I like the attention like a
lots of attention is on me in
relationships have you ever been cheated
on no you feel like if someone cheats
that they can continue a relationship I
don't think it's black and white
cheating is even like a slippery term
like it's all very slippery are you a
cheater